News Reporter:
Tonight's top story, Hurricane
Katrina
News Reporter:
could be one of the biggest
storms to ever hit this country.
George Bush:
We cannot stress enough the
danger this hurricane poses to gulf coast communities.
♪♪
Nurse:
We need help.
We're running out of food
and water.
Nurse:
We can't take it much longer.
Dr. Anna Pou
There's nothing else to do for
them.
Except to make them comfortable.
Dr. Anna Pou:
Every single one of us
did everything we could.
Dr. Anna Pou:
And everybody in that hospital
was treated with dignity.
State Attorney:
They found 45 dead bodies.
Now does that make any sense to
you?
State Attorney:
45 dead patients.
Given the conditions, maybe 45
patients succumbed.
Maybe they didn't.